on July 16 1945 the United States tested
the first atomic bomb called Trinity
over the next five decades the country
tested more than 200 bombs in the
atmosphere the explosions called shots
were recorded by dozens of high-speed
cameras on film for analysis of the
bombs destructive power now there's a
race on to preserve and digitize those
films thousands of them so some of the
cans that we opened up especially the
Trinity films are quite old those that
actually turned to dust and had to be
destroyed
nuclear physicist Greg sprigs is leading
the effort at Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory he's working with
film specialists Jim Moy to scan and
analyze those original test films the
u.s. stopped testing nuclear bombs in
1992 and these films are now some of the
best data scientists have to work with
so this particular film was running
about 1500 frames a second so we not
only captured the shock wave the
reflected shock wave law also able to
get the yield off of it and now we're
also watching how the mushroom cloud
forms sprig saw his first atomic bomb in
1962 when I was a kid my my dad was in
the military was in the Navy and he was
stationed on Midway Island up the middle
of the Pacific and they were doing some
high altitude testing over Johnson
Island starfish emanated and its plan
strengthened high shot was detonated
about 10:00 p.m. it was pitch black
outside when it went off the sky it
looked like it was
No and it took about 15 minutes for the
sky to go through all these different
colors and end up coming back to being
pitch black again had I known I was
gonna be a nuclear engineer later on or
a nuclear physicist I would have paid
more attention but to me it was just a
bright flash in those days figuring out
the power of a bomb was done by
measuring the size of the mushroom cloud
shockwaves or recorded light intensity
of an explosion in a bomb film and it
was done by hand they would have taken
an army of workers a month to just get
the light pulse off of one film and the
Spriggs has discovered that data was
often scattered and calculations off by
as much as 20% we were trying to figure
out if there was actually some piece of
physics that we were missing the only
way to resolve this was to get a hold of
the original films and start to
reanalyze him to find out whether the
data was valid and we were actually
missing a piece of physics or the
physics is ok and the data was not that
good now they have a Swedish film
scanner and sophisticated computer
models mowing through miles of film to
get a better sense of the power fallout
and potential destruction of a nuclear
bomb we're very hopeful that we're gonna
learn some new things here that they
just did not have the technology to do
back in the 50s and the 60s
[Music]